so with that I want to bring the one and
only Kevin Smith up
hey
[Applause]
um all right kids real talk I was how
many people were here for the Marvel
panel
um I was I used my position of authority
to get backstage a little bit early and
uh Maurice was nice enough to let us sit
in the back I sat with uh Harley my
daughter's with me
um Austin was with us Jen my wife and uh
Chelsea was there too so we're sitting
in the back watching the panel like
everybody else but from a screen out
back and then they're showing the
trailers and stuff they showed She-Hulk
and it was [ __ ] legit funny reminded
me of the John Byrne run of the book
she'd talk to the [ __ ] camera broke
the fourth wall that was amazing then
they showed us [ __ ] secret Invasion
which [ __ ] looked intense like I had
no idea I thought it was gonna be the
scroll Comedy Hour but it's not that at
all it's [ __ ] really intense
then they [ __ ] ruined Comic-Con for
me by showing me the most beautiful
[ __ ] Guardians of the Galaxy trailer
oh my God
we'll get back to that in a minute and
then after that [ __ ] wakanda forever
which was absolute [ __ ] magic man
like
so we were sitting there uh watching the
Guardians trailer and you know before
everybody comes up they're like
processing in front of us backstage and
[ __ ] so we're like oh [ __ ] there's that
person that there's that person and [ __ ]
and I get really nerdy about directors
where I was just like oh there's James
Gunn oh there's Ryan coogler and [ __ ]
like that
so James comes up before he came up they
they're all standing back there as a
group watching uh the trailer and so I'm
I'm focused on the trailer they're also
focused on the trailer without spoiling
at a lot of people have seen the trailer
there's a [ __ ] shot of little rocket
in the trailer
that [ __ ] destroyed me and
instantly I weld up with [ __ ] tears
and I know that doesn't mean anything
anymore because I cry at everything I as
a middle-aged Stoner everything touches
me
but I swear to God in that moment I felt
inestimable [ __ ] joy and an absolute
[ __ ] respect
for James Gunn I was like it was such a
perfect the whole [ __ ] trailer is an
emotional [ __ ] experience and I was
crying backstage and then I feel this
[ __ ] hand come down on my leg so
[ __ ] hard and I looked over and my
kid is crying harder than me
and they were both just bawling together
and then there was like a secondary
rocket shot and it was like oh
and I'll never forget it man I'll go to
the My Grave one day and I'll never one
of the last things I imagine I'll see is
that real shared moment that's a pure
Comic-Con moment I'm here to like you
know essentially sell my Wares we've
been doing the movies pop up I'm going
to show you clerks 3 stuff but in that
moment I was not a Creator I was pure
[ __ ] fan and there I was with another
pure [ __ ] fan just soaking it up man
I appreciate that that's why I like I
love the [ __ ] Marvel movies so much
they make me feel like a kid they make
me feel the same way I felt when I would
go to the movies in the 70s and the 80s
and I looked up to movies and that was
like everything and just because I I get
to work in them that doesn't change like
people are always like you're gonna make
one of those Marvel movies I was like
they'll never let me number one
but number two even if they gave me
carte blanche I would be like honestly
no put me in one of those [ __ ]
like that that's good for my brand but
making one of them is just not in my DNA
that's my comfort zone that's where I go
to get fed if you're like where is the
chef go [ __ ] before he prepares a
meal that's the [ __ ] that feeds my heart
and soul and I know some people are like
what it's not Cinema it's absolute
[ __ ] cinnamon to me because it moves
me so incredibly much and that
without I'm not pointing fingers and
saying like somebody said that I've
heard that from many many people uh over
the years every time I talk about how
much I love uh the Marvel movies every
time we do an episode of fat man beyond
and [ __ ] and I talk about oh my God I
[ __ ] love what they did this time
there's like [ __ ] a thousand people
who are like get off their [ __ ]
payroll you cook you know and
and I'm like if I could get paid to like
Marvel I'd quit making those lousy ass
movies man like
they don't pay you for that kind of [ __ ]
you just do it because you absolutely
[ __ ] love it and I I love it I sat
back there and I was a [ __ ] kid again
I'm a 51 year old man and I'm out here
to present the movie that I made and
[ __ ] like that but back there I was gone
I was just a kid looking up at the
screen going like we got to see that it
took me right back I'm sitting next to
my kid and my kid's 23 now she's growing
up and stuff like that but like I used
to go to the movies with my father when
I was a kid he used to pull me out of
school I've talked about this many times
he'd pull me out of school to go see
movies matinees of movies and stuff and
the idea was I liked movies so he was
like look the fat one likes movies
maybe that's the thing we could do
together I don't mind movies he seems
way into it so I'm gonna take him to the
movies and my mom was like your dad's
going to take you to the movies see a
matinee today and it was a school day
and I was like well how are we going to
do that I'm going to school and she was
like he's going to come pick you up at
12 o'clock and he's going to bring you
to the movies and I was like what do I
tell sister Teresa and [ __ ] I went to a
Catholic School our lady Perpetual Help
and uh my mom was like just tell him
your aunt died
because my mom was a really good
Catholic and um
and so I went into school and uh at noon
my father showed up and they brought me
down to the office and like oh my God
Kevin you didn't tell us your father
came to pick you up for a funeral I said
yeah my aunt died man so he said like
we'll put her in our prayers I was like
don't bother and uh
I joined my dad my dad took me to the
movies man first movie like date that we
had was Raiders of the Lost Ark
and
there's something very magical happened
in the in that screening man uh number
one I saw like one of the greatest
movies of all time in real time a lot of
people saw it on video later on some
people catching up with it now and [ __ ]
I remember exactly where the [ __ ] I was
it was opening day and I was at a
matinee with my father and he kept
talking about the whole ride to the
movie theater it was just like this
movie I think it's like the movies I
grew up watching and I was like what do
you mean he's like we used to go see
Cliffhangers when I was a kid and he
would see a cereal and it would end you
had to come back the next week to see it
and he said the common attraction makes
it look like that I was like okay and we
went and I remember being way more into
seeing Superman 2 which was coming soon
and they put out like a Lobby program
book and I said I asked my father I said
can I get that can I they used to sell
books in the lobby with popcorn to show
you what the movie was going to be when
it came so he got me that but he was
like I think you should pay attention to
this movie you're gonna like it I didn't
know [ __ ] [ __ ] about Indiana Jones I
hadn't met him yet and [ __ ] so there we
go into this movie theater and my father
was always my father you know an
authority figure and [ __ ] I love them to
death don't get me wrong but like we
didn't have like a super close
relationship where he poured his heart
out to me that's the father I was to my
kid because I'm a stoner so I'm like
everything's [ __ ] beautiful man you
know
so that's the world she grew up in my
father kind of played it more close to
the vest and and he was not a cold man
but I should start to the imagination
but he was Dad the authority figure and
[ __ ] like he's the one that had the job
and [ __ ] paid the bills and when he
was sleeping you had to be quiet and
[ __ ] it was just Dad that's what I
always thought of mass sitting next to
him in a movie theater watching Raiders
of the Lost Ark
he stopped being dead and that's where I
saw Don my father the boy who used to go
to the movies because he was filled with
[ __ ] Glee as we watched this movie
and I swear to God man same thing
happened to me when I was a kid that's
why it was such a bizarre wonderful
moment backstage I felt a very heavy
hand hit my [ __ ] leg and I looked
over and it was my father who was
gripped with [ __ ] excitement and he
said I knew it this is exactly like the
movies I used to go see when I was a kid
isn't this [ __ ] great and a man who
at that point was maybe 46 looked like
he was [ __ ] six years old and I got
to see my father My real father for the
first time not the veneer of like that's
dad the human being underneath I learned
so much about my father sitting next to
him in a movie theater over and over
again what made him laugh what made him
[ __ ] cry which will blow a kid's mind
man I never saw my dad cry until we were
in a movie theater there he is crying
during raging [ __ ] ball and I was
like you're allowed to do that
like I learned so much sitting next to
him in the movies and and it led
eventually to a life where I became a
filmmaker and so I know what it's like
to pull the levers and work the magic
the smoke and mirrors and [ __ ] but I
swear to Christ as I sat backstage
all of that fell away and I was [ __ ]
10 years old 11 years old sitting next
to my father again that's how powerful a
[ __ ] movie can be man they can bring
the dead back for just a few [ __ ]
seconds
hmm
I swear to God I I really if I my mom
raised me very polite and [ __ ] so I
don't like to insinuate myself into
situations unless I'm invited but when
James Gunn came off stage I wanted to
tackle him and [ __ ] kiss him like a
cartoon character and [ __ ]
because I was like Jesus Christ you have
no right to stick the landing not not
just stick The Landing but give us such
a beautiful conclusion for a third
[ __ ] movie who does that [ __ ]
foreign
now I've been hearing about Hall h all
day and all week and [ __ ] and everybody
does big things here this morning
[ __ ] uh Dwayne The Rock Johnson
showed up cosplaying
and apparently Rose into the [ __ ] sky
worked [ __ ] magic and everybody's
chest lit up and [ __ ] like that that's
Warner Brothers money right there
we worked for Lionsgate ladies and
gentlemen
early on they were just like how big do
you want to go at Comic-Con I was like
not really I was like this is again this
ain't a brand new movie it's like clerks
with a three in it so
we could probably keep it toned and
tasteful and [ __ ] like that the good
Folks at Lionsgate have been so
wonderful to us they put together
fantastic posters I don't know if you
saw them but the [ __ ] marketing
campaign is wonderful the trailer that
they cut is [ __ ] phenomenal man
absolutely I was so in love with what
they did trailer cutting as an art form
that I have no skill out give it up for
the Lionsgate people man they [ __ ]
oh they have not let us down
so when it came to this I was like
throttle back kids like [ __ ] you
don't have to do [ __ ] man like they were
like we're gonna do a booth at Lionsgate
we're gonna at Comic Con on the floor
the Lionsgate Booth is going to be you
sharing it with Hunger Games and [ __ ]
and I was just like oh [ __ ] I've heard
of that
that will make this booth very popular
and [ __ ] and then at a certain point
they're like Hunger Games ain't coming
it's just [ __ ] clerks man and I was
like [ __ ] Katniss we win
foreign
so they were like we want to put
together like a quick stop counter on
the floor I was like oh it sounds like a
lot of hassle please don't and they did
and it's [ __ ] darling and I went to
the floor and took pictures with people
and [ __ ] it's like a hobbit version of
Quick Stop just very small I was down on
my knees taking pictures and [ __ ]
um it was lovely they're they're they've
made dreams come true they made this
dream come true for me clerks three is a
movie I've been trying to make for 10
[ __ ] years man it took a minute and
[ __ ] and it was only by the good graces
of Lionsgate that it happened and the
good graces of you I'm going to tell you
a story and how you manifested this
movie so when people don't like clerks
three I'm gonna tell them to blame your
[ __ ] asses
uh here's the story man we made this
movie uh last time I was on this stage
as Eddie mentioned man uh was 2019. I I
got an inkpot award which I still have
on my shelf is amazing but we were here
with Jay and Silent Bob reboot man we
announced the tour we put tickets on
sale and [ __ ]
so um in we took that movie out in the
world we toured it and when it was done
it went to Home Video Lionsgate had home
video and not just home video of
streaming and [ __ ] that's what I think
of when I think of Home Video now
Lionsgate still makes like DVDs and
Blu-rays and [ __ ] so they sold DVDs and
Blu-rays of Jay and Silent Bob reboot
and apparently sold enough to reach out
to us and say we sold [ __ ] so many
DVDs and Blu-rays that if you ever want
to make more of this Jay and Silent Bob
[ __ ]
as long as it's under this price point
[ __ ] have a go at it and [ __ ] the
only reason we got to do that is because
you you bought Hardware kids thank you
for that man
thank you for buying physical media
so because of that we're gonna give you
a reward man I am not clever like the
good Folks at Warner Brothers I'm not
going to raise anybody up into the air
uh I did not bring anything nearly as
moving as the Guardians the Galaxy uh
trailer Nora is [ __ ] sweeping an epic
as wakanda forever
um but I brought something that I cut
out of my [ __ ] broken stented heart
and put together with a bunch of friends
and [ __ ] who have been doing the same
version of the story with for nearly 30
years
um held it together with a lot of spit
glue and uh and absolute affection and I
think we got something for you we're
going to show you the entire first five
minutes of Clerks three
now uh spoilers in advance uh you know
because I watched the [ __ ] Marvel
trailers backstage and I was on the edge
of my seat and I was desperately
listening for the dialogue like
sometimes it's so boomy you can't hear
the dialogue and people are talking
about staging and you can't shush them
because they're all [ __ ] Marvel
people somebody was talking I wanted to
be like shut the [ __ ] up it was Kevin
feige
um the only Kevin that [ __ ] matters
at Comic-Con the Kevin that must be
saved at all costs and [ __ ]
so here you won't struggle to listen to
dialogue it's a die believe it or not in
a Kevin Smith movie it's a fairly
dialogue free opening five minutes
that's because I had good friends of
mine do the speaking for me I reached
out to some local Jersey musicians by
the name of My Chemical Romance
and so essentially what you're going to
see is the owner of our movie but what
also functions as a fairly decent music
video for a very popular my chem song
um
we're gonna watch this and I'm gonna
bring out all the magical people that
made this happen man so for for Here We
Go kids uh First Look anywhere for
anybody and [ __ ] uh Here Comes Dwayne
The Rock Johnson hovering into the air
get ready for lightning bolts to go
across your chests ladies and gentlemen
I'll give you the first five minutes of
Clerks three
oh my God just for one second I stopped
feeling like Kevin Smith start feeling
like Kevin foggy man that was
that was amazing let me introduce you to
the fine folks who've made clerks three
with me as well as clerks too as well as
the original clerks ladies and gentlemen
joining us in the viewsk universe for
the first time uh you probably saw him
if you ever saw me do the TBS uh
competition sitcom was uh was called
celebrity show off we did a shortcom
that was called sun and lockdown in
which uh my daughter's boyfriend Austin
played a version of Austin that I
bickered with and battled with we had a
good time doing it he's a wonderful
[ __ ] actor and [ __ ] and so he plays a
brand new character in our movie who's
very disturbingly into crypto
and his name is blockchain Coltrane uh
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Austin Zager
uh next up ladies and gentlemen am I
right yes I'm right uh she's been with
me since the beginning man since we
started this whole clerks Journey uh and
she has uh in real life as far as I know
not sucked 37 dicks give it up for
Marilyn gigliotti
uh next up we got our precious little
Elias from clerks too in this movie if
you've seen the trailer he's grown up in
weird and wonderful ways man just like
the man who plays him give it up for the
great Trevor Fuhrman ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
yeah
uh the next guy I bring out you seem to
enjoy his presence in the trailer I've
been standing next to him professionally
and personally for the better part of 30
plus years ladies and gentlemen him and
I are in Shrine together forever in the
cement at growman's Chinese Theater
right next to one another uh Silent Bob
and of course Jay himself give it up for
Jason yo
[Applause]
yes she said Sexy [ __ ] isn't he dressed
nicely
[Music]
I asked him before I was like did you
bring a dresser do you hire a stylist
and [ __ ] and he was like no I went to a
store and I bought these things
very proud of his outfit
um look pictures called clerks this is
clerks three everything I've done is
predicated on that first movie it's not
clerk it's Clerk's plural there's two of
them so it's very hard to separate these
two uh in real life in my head and in my
heart man uh the co-architects of the
viewist universe people I've been
playing with since I was relative
relatively a kid at least relative till
now man we started working on clerks
when I was 22. I'm 51 years old now so
29 years I've been playing with these
adult children who give me so much
[ __ ] happiness welcome both Dante and
Randall Brian o'holland and Jeff
Anderson
[Applause]
uh okay uh before we're gonna pretty
much you know because things got started
a little bit late and stuff and uh
there's a Hollywood Babylon show I gotta
do later on We're Gonna Keep It kind of
tight we will jump to q a but before we
do that I want to give everyone a chance
to talk and uh ask him across the boards
how was it watching the opening five
minutes with the audience start with you
uh it was incredible
yeah
they want to hear from everyone else
Marilyn what was it like watching these
I know neither of you two kids are
represented in the first few minutes and
neither is Trevor he shows up and stuff
but what was it like watching even even
though that
um for me well and I told you when I
read I think it was the first draft that
I was excited with the music that was
going to be starting because I love I
love My Chemical Romance and that
particular song
um so yeah it's just
yeah it gets you in the mood to just
want to see more good
I hope you're right Trev
yeah I don't know I just hope you guys
like it
that's all
thank you for that very touching take on
welcome Trevor
uh Mr Muse I found myself really fixated
on the car that Brian pulled up in
because you know the last two movies he
was he was driving like a like a station
wagon Caprice Classic or something like
and all of a sudden now you got like a
really sweet like minivan or something
but I don't know that's what I was but
I'm excited I I really am it'll be nice
to sit with a uh with a bunch of people
and watch the movie from beginning ten
because that was just a taste of it
um and it seemed to be enjoyable for you
guys I think right
so it'll be nice to listen to sit in the
movie theater and listen to the movie
from beginning to end with people so I'm
excited
Jefe Anderson what do you think uh you
know I was back there and I was watching
it and I got a little tear in my eye
and I felt this heavy hand on my ball
and it was Muse
a moment he'll never forget
this is why you don't [ __ ] share
things man
Doh Brian o'holland what'd you think
well first of all uh hello Hall h
uh is this your is this a first Hall h
for all for you yes it's uh that's what
it's like yeah many times in the
audience Watcher of you and your your
hall H's first time on the stage it's
like you know when you call into a radio
station long time listener first time
caller yeah that's how it feels right
now I'm I'm odd because I've watched so
many haul age panels of other things
just like the Marvel stuff and I get
choked up and engrossed like a fan and
so I watched it out here I decided to
come along and just sit and just watch
it as an audience member and I I got
choked up I'm not gonna lie it's 30
years people that we've been I've been
not even supposed to be here today huh
but I can honestly say today I'm so
grateful to be here today
um what says uh what's been everyone's
experience at a Comic Con so far
something we could all uh universally uh
relate to because everyone's here
attending Comic-Con is this your first
Comic-Con
yeah this is my first Comic-Con and
what's it been like for you this is
crazy this is insane uh thank you guys
all wow thank you
let's count on you for so much content
um I just got here
um what about you Marilyn how's it but
you've been to calm before I've been
coming pretty much every year since
2010 and
I still don't know what to do with
myself other than when I'm here to do
it's like I I wander around aimlessly
and I wish I didn't because I really
want to experience
Comic-Con the way you guys do but I just
never know what to do with myself you
know it's but it's fun to be here anyway
you need to find a buddy you should
latch on to someone like hey man do you
as anyone know and then you can hang out
right they could show you around and all
that look you got a bunch of people
waving their hands next year
just so you know don't take the latching
on to somebody advice from Jay I saw
what he was latching on Backstage my
balls
what does it say right here sorry please
be aware that many members of your
audience may be under 18 years of age
man come on guys jeez my basketball
can't bring him anywhere I'm glad she
pointed that out well that it actually
does say that the first time here last
time here [ __ ]
[Applause]
are we taking the same car out of here
because you're gone too now
Trev first Comic-Con for you yeah I've
never been here before I think it's
pretty cool because I I grew up watching
uh like Star Trek the Next Generation
and reading X-Men and none of that stuff
was okay when I was a kid
and like I did not fit in at all so I I
find it kind of heartwarming to see that
uh all us nerds have found one another
at last and in sufficient numbers
we can bring them down you [ __ ]
foreign
this is your you've been coming to
Comic-Con with me we've been coming
together since 1995. next time we came
was we showed Mallrats at the Horton
Plaza like a sneak previewing yeah
um was uh what's it like for you to be
here after all this time you're a
[ __ ] fixture now it's you know every
year it uh I get so excited every
again as much as as often as I've come
and as many times I've come I still get
excited each time because it's like as
soon as you get to you get in you
finally get through the traffic and you
get in your room it's like you look out
and you just the cause playing and it's
cool for me and for us I'm for you too
I'm sorry is going out and seeing how
it's grown it's like I remember it used
to be like lots of uh vendors and Warner
Brothers maybe maybe DC I don't know
whatever would have a big booth in the
middle of the convention hall but now
it's like Funko you know gentle giant uh
Sideshow like there is so much to see
and each time I walk the floor and I'm
like I'll like start talking I was
streaming the other day on my twitch and
I was trying to walk the hall but I
couldn't really do it because I'd be
like oh and I like move over here and
I'd be holding the camera here and I was
like oh sorry guys look what I just saw
and then I'd see something else so again
for me is is every time I come
um I I get excited and it's it's just
amazing man it really is I was bombed
the last two years
um that you know they had to close it
down I was shocked I was like I thought
they would make it through of everything
but he wasn't aware it was closed for
the last three years so he was only sad
about the last two and then he got the
memo he's like what the [ __ ] it isn't
been three has it has been three man
this is 2022 last time we all know
21. and we're here
22 so that's three this is three years
since the last time we were here we
can't do basic math in front of these
[ __ ] people the time for that was in
grade school [ __ ] no Jeff without
answering any arithmetic questions how
have you enjoyed Comic-Con
um I you know I haven't done the cons
This was um I actually started doing
cons right before the pandemic hit I did
two right before the pandemic I think I
brought it on
um and so coming here this is my first
time obviously to Comic-Con uh the thing
for me is I I've never really done these
things so it's great to meet you guys
and and it's amazing how much love you
have for this movie and for us sitting
here and that's been the coolest thing
for me to finally come out of my cabin
in the woods and uh experience literally
literally literally he's got bears and
[ __ ] by his house that's cool
and his address is no I'm just kidding
Brian you know uh I was here with you
guys for 2019 uh promoting reboot with
you guys that was a great experience you
you were hosting out on the IMDb boat
which was like man we can redo
Gilligan's Island with just this boat
alone let's do it viewers Gillian's
Island
um and seeing the you know missing this
for the past couple of years it was sad
uh three I believe the past two years
yeah okay we've been over this I was
actually here three years ago 100
where is everybody playing different
characters and [ __ ]
but if you're like wow there's no line
for whole age
I'm so [ __ ] lucky this year
but it's great it's good to be back and
this time not only am I here promoting
promoting for clerks three that I'm I'm
on the stage with you and here in front
of the Great Hall age people I saw you
guys waiting in line outside and stuff
and thank God the weather has been kind
of cooperating it's not been sweltering
any deadly Kate I caught in previous
years and uh I'm just so amped to be
here and I want to talk more about
clerks three and like Jeff we are so
just so touched by the love that you all
are giving us sorry that
hi there
what is this The Crying Game Stop it
[Applause]
see I'm not the only [ __ ] who cries in
Hall age
I understand where him and his dad come
from on this and the same it is it's
just you know you guys have love for a
[ __ ] movie that's been around 30
[ __ ] years and uh you all still come
out for it and I think when you see it
and you all will see it right thank you
yeah I am threatening them movie anyway
um the number three by the way uh when
you see it and you see what the love
that was put into this film and the back
to the funniness that we always love uh
I can't wait to see you guys next year
to hear what the response is so
um but I'll know because you'll go to
the theaters to watch what the response
will be is we we did well because we do
well this time then Amal rats 2 comes
next and maybe the Clark's cartoon yes
you know fingers crossed and the good
folks of Lionsgate were really cool and
like Kevin said like you make more of
these Jay and Silent Bob [ __ ] well
with this bet on budget we'll totally do
more so we're ready to do a lot of that
[ __ ] for more
um the movie I'm happy to report turned
out uh great the dream going into it is
like man I hope this [ __ ] works
um but I had very able players to bring
it to life a script is always just a
blueprint it's what the performer the
performances the performers bring to the
table and all of these cats none of them
executed the movie thank God it's alive
they all elevated the [ __ ] picture
every one of them honestly this is the
most beautiful movie I've ever made
um it's funny still but it is a weirdly
profound Journey for this Dopey little
story of two dudes who have been in the
same place for like nearly 30 years and
stuff I saw some people online when the
trailer dropped somebody was just like I
think it's [ __ ] sad that they're
still at that store
and I had to write like they own that
[ __ ] store now and they're like all
right that's okay
um I can't wait to show you what they've
all done now I'm here all the time and I
Chit Chat constantly and I'm always
answering questions so we're going to
open up the mic and I encourage you to
take the opportunity to hit all these uh
unicorns with questions man I'm always
around you can always catch me so let's
uh hit a mic turn on a light oh why
hello wow that was cool good seeing you
the first question in the night give it
up from ladies and gentlemen is Brave
hi Kevin it's Mike good seeing you good
good seeing you too you know just like
you said hell you and your father
watched the movie together and what we
saw today it was nice to have my son
with me so he could be a part of what we
saw and like when uh the um a black
panther Forever Came he grabbed my hand
and he said dad I have to go to the
bathroom
and so and so we had to go run over to
the bathroom because you know as a
father I got to be there for him you do
do you have to be there you have to be
there so that's my moment that I will
always remember with black panther
because being with my son as you're
dragging her to the bathroom you piece
of [ __ ] I want to watch this exactly but
you got to be a dad that's a beautiful
dad story give it up for that man that's
phenomenal
so Kevin behind me is your little buddy
oh
how are you good oh you're like the
miniature version I am
he's even wearing Batman for you I saw
that I like Batman too
uh are you gonna see this movie when it
comes out if you are somebody's gonna
have to explain a lot of [ __ ] to you
a lot of Concepts in the movie might be
a little but yeah okay you get it though
okay so go
the short answer is
at WonderCon we you asked him a question
about
uh why you like superheroes yes so
here's his answer oh my God you took
this many months to come up with a
response yes
definitely like five minutes
okay but fair enough fair enough these
people are away funnier than any of us
kid do you want to be in clerks four
the variance of you well it depends what
how this answer goes let's hear the
question that I asked at WonderCon posed
to the young gentleman was what was it
why do you like superheroes why do you
like superheroes I told them a very
long-winded story about why I like
superheroes and I asked why do you like
him he was like I don't know and I said
well you think about it and [ __ ] get
back to me he [ __ ] took me seriously
man here we are
okay give us your answer we're all
listening the floor is yours the short
answer is I like how they kick butt
the more advanced answer is I like to
see them kick butt because I've seen a
lot of movies Marvel and DC except for
the Green Lantern because my dad says it
blows
laughs
[Applause]
oh kid I'm signing you up for clerks
four through nine
this panel you'll be playing Randall
[Applause]
uh I like this kid
but I like to see their super powers and
fight and fight girls and their cool
weapons and gadgets now I have a
question for you why do you use the
F-bomb so much
burn
[Applause]
I mean
[ __ ] it I don't know
it's a weird question my mother asks it
all the time too because my mother's
like I raised you and I never cursed
around and my mother didn't she wouldn't
even say hell she would say oh double
hockey sticks I had to spell [ __ ] out
and whatnot so my mom is always baffled
like where did this come from what part
of your life were you able to say these
things why do you say uh [ __ ] so much
and I honestly like I've thought about
it for the better part of 29 years I
think it's Jason Muse's fault
thank you
he just made it so attractive like Jason
Mew is one of my absolute Heroes you
could tell I love him so much I put him
in all the movies and [ __ ] like that
he's my rocket sauce like he's my
[ __ ] he's the you know the the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that they stuck in Captain
America the secret Soldier serum and
[ __ ] he's the battery if I'm the ever
ready everybody and [ __ ] if that still
exists or Energizer Bunny you know what
that [ __ ] is old commercial never mind
that [ __ ] keep me going and stuff
like that because he's been such a
freeing personality to know my whole
life one of the freest people I've ever
known one of the most entertaining one
of the purest [ __ ] hearts a million
dollar heart nickel [ __ ] head but a
million dollar heart
so he's been the the secret sauce and
everything and his casual nature with
let's say coarse language and overuse of
the term [ __ ] as a modifier
sank in over time because I was like I
think I'd rather live my life like him
and so that's where it comes from so if
you're mad there's that bad boy right
there
perspective nobody ever heard me curse
until I said Clerks
is that right I swear to God
I'm sorry I
feel like I ruined a virgin Soul
something pure
is that is that we good yeah or is there
more to the letter no there's more I
just want to say Kevin when uh Shatner
and Shatner and you did that thing with
Shatner and the acting thing that was
priceless it was beautiful you set that
up didn't you uh you were there you were
there you asked one of the questions
yeah yeah thank you sir thank you there
was nothing more to that letter no that
was it that was it give it up for him
that was a beautiful piece of writing
excellent job
what's your name my friend I'm Rolando
give it up for Rolando
yeah I'm a Mexican from Vancouver
actually that's weird but that's who I
am
so you Kevin Smith you changed my life
you know I think in the Vancouver
animation industry since 2016 where I
also love like action and everything
that you can see on the screen so before
I listen to your comic companion back on
2018 I was not super happy about just
being an animator working all day in
front of a computer I wanted more so
after your panel on 2019 and everything
you said about your unfortunate heart
attack I came out of these same room so
inspired that I signed up for every
single Indie filmmaking Facebook group
in Vancouver and with that I was every
single weekend of my life volunteering
on every single Indie movie sets I could
be on as gaffer great BG actor the BTS
photographer art Department Etc you name
it so weekdays I was an animator and
weekends I was on movie sets then the
pandemic started but that didn't stop me
so I initiated a podcast about film for
Spanish people I wrote some short films
and I also made all the courses and
certifications you needed to join the
union dgc I haven't joined yet because
I'm missing actual Union hours that are
pretty hard to get but I won't give up
until I get into that Union because I
love this industry and all this has been
thanked to the inspiration you you Kevin
Smith gave me on 2018 so I now just
wanted to thank you and let you know
that you changed my life in a fantastic
way
thank you
first off you can work for me any day
man bring that attitude to work that's
lovely second off that moves me to to
near tears my friend uh the kid who
started this journey who like made
clerks I would love to go back in time
and tell him just that sampling of that
story like the trickle-down impact that
the thing that we all made together when
we were kids would have on people thank
you for for for giving me credit that I
don't deserve because I've listened to
that story very closely and you sound
like the hero of that [ __ ] you
did all the work man well you gave me
the Boost you know
a lot of people a lot of people listen
not everybody hears man and you did and
you went and made it happen
um it sounds I don't want this to sound
condescending but like I'm proud of you
like that's tremendous
um
let me get your information Vancouver
you say yeah I live in Vancouver I work
up there all the time and [ __ ] yeah I
know
but if he's like what
you Shifty [ __ ] well that might
be fine
um tell you what man uh see this guy
here with the camera dressed like a punk
he's waving his hand as Dr Josh Rouse
you give me your information man we're
gonna work together is that cool yeah
yeah sure yeah perfect thank you for
sharing all that so should I go to him
or I think should I go to him now like
okay go to him now
oh that was [ __ ] beautiful man [ __ ]
like that's honestly that's my life
people say wonderful things like that to
me and it's like it just makes like
people think like oh you're in the movie
business you must make a lot of money
not really not in Kevin Smith movies and
[ __ ] but you get paid in that that's the
richest currency you could [ __ ] feel
man somebody's saying something like
that to you like you changed their
[ __ ] life and [ __ ] but I didn't you
did well done you what's your name uh my
name is Michael hi real quick hello
Michael everyone give it up for Michael
hello Michael hey
it's yeah it's so surreal it's so great
to be back I was here 2019 all day
through Marvel staying my Comic-Con
tradition is
I come into college at some point in the
day then everybody else I'm with leaves
me and I hang back here to see you
fine people
party we can go see [ __ ] you're like
you're like no I'm just gonna hang here
smack this [ __ ] old [ __ ] they're like
we're gonna go get Mexican food we'll
see you later anyway I appreciate that
man thank you for for leaving friends
behind to [ __ ] well they left me
that's true good point [ __ ] them
um no but tell them for uh for me thank
you for indulging your passion and stuff
not pulling you away because if they
were true friends they'd be like [ __ ]
Kevin Smith come with us but they let
you do your thing that's very sweet yeah
for sure um so two things two quick
things before uh my actual question so
one uh similar to the previous fellow I
just want to thank you and let you know
just how much of an influence and
inspiration you are to me as well I mean
as a person as an artist and then just
your general Outlook and everything and
just
it's it's so it's it's just so great and
I just also yeah oh sorry what I said
thank you man I think it's I think
you're talking to me
no
not bad pillow yeah I kill Lopez for
Life Trevor you know how it goes
um
but I also just it's also kind of as
happy as I am it's also kind of
Bittersweet for me to be here and
talking to you and seeing you guys uh
with clerks 3 coming out my one of my
really good friends and also uh podcast
co-host that we like started uh in the
midst of all the lockdown times and
everything uh he passed away last
November 2021 yeah it was it was an
accident super young only like a year
older than me yeah we were both really
we were both really big fans ears too he
was one of the few friends I actually
had that I could talk about your stuff
with so like that was really great you
made it was sad and somehow you made it
sadder man
we were like and he loved you but he's
gone like yeah for sure he did your uh
he did
um Loki's Loki's monologue and
everything in his class in high school I
like I always wanted to see footage of
that but yeah he's like that was what
was his name let's bring him to life for
a little while his name is uh was Andrew
Zeeman but he was also in addition to
being a podcaster he was also a rapper
uh his name was Drew hush Dru space hush
as in Tommy Elliott hush because he was
a big comic guy too so wow yeah
for Drew man
that's really beautiful thank you for
sharing that that's incredibly
meaningful as I said before like that's
that's my currency that's the fuel that
I I run on [ __ ] like that like for a guy
who made a series of goofy ass movies
with Jay and Silent Bob people people
tell you such incredibly powerful things
about what these movies have meant to
them and I always loved my movies don't
get me wrong I was never dismissive of
them I'm a big Kevin Smith fan
um but you know they're very
self-serving they're incredibly
masturbatory they're all for me it's
just me jerking off all over myself and
[ __ ] can confirm
laughs
but but when people talk to you about
like or tell me what the movies have
meant to them it's a reminder that like
I'm not on this journey alone you a lot
of you've been on it with me for for
many many years at this point and the
movies mean something to you in the way
they mean something to me but have in
this completely different way in this
completely different narrative and how
they fit in into your lives and stuff
like that and then you all grow up and
have children and then introduce me to
the kids and talk about how you share
the movies with your kids and it takes
me right back to my father where I was
like he took me to the movies because I
was the fat one so I get it and if
they're standing there with a kid the
kid's like wait am I the fat one
so thank you that means the [ __ ]
world thank you can I name drop the
podcast yeah do it do it so it's called
if anyone's curious It's Like on Apple
Spotify it's called two old souls t-o-o
like as in we're too old for this [ __ ]
so yeah we did a whole episode covering
all the viewsq stuff up through reboot
so how many episodes did you do before
you lost it I think we got like
somewhere in the 25 to 30 range I'm
still kind of doing the posthumous
releases and stuff but yeah how precious
to still have that to have that voice
captured that's the magic of podcasts
man I know they become very popular
obviously but I've been doing this [ __ ]
since 2007 and just capturing voices of
people that you love people that you
admire and stuff like that we all take
pictures because we got cell phones with
cameras and [ __ ] but nobody really
thinks to capture motherfucker's voice
and that's the first thing you lose
later in life and stuff so how awesome
that you have his voice captured forever
well done absolutely and then okay I do
have a question for the rest of the your
crew is that cool please oh my God
absolutely so with the likes
not even semi but like very
autobiographical nature of your work
have with all your movies I'm I have a
question for all of you guys like what's
what's it like to
be sort of acting out parts of Kevin's
story all you know through the years
whether you're playing someone who's
like a composite of people he's known or
if you're kind of playing a version of
him you know at different points in his
life so yeah just curious what's and
Kevin what's that what's that like for
you to watch that sort of play out as
you process and make sense of the
experiences that you've had through your
art
uh I'll jump and go first then give it
over to them my I had the closest story
that I think could maybe answer the
question is my mom watched
um
uh the oh she watched all of it Jay and
Silent Bob reboot but the opening of Jay
and Silent Bob reboot when my mom was
watching and she started crying and I
you know for a minute I was like she was
like oh first Tusk now this like he's
[ __ ] ruined but
I was like what's the matter are you
okay and she was just like
I did that I pulled up to that store and
I would drop you off I don't know how
many times I did it and it's just so
weird I know you've been making movies
for a while and I know you've done the
same shot in movies before but just
seeing that vehicle pull up in front of
the store she's like that's my life too
which is kind of like a theme that runs
through clerks three Randall is making
the story of his life Randall forgets
that his life is shared by a lot of
other people and stuff
um so for me my mom crystallized it you
know I I get so lost in it that it goes
from memory to to artifice where I take
something real and turn it into
something for the movie and stuff and
then it belongs to the movie and stops
being mine for example the heart attack
is no longer mine it's Randall's heart
attack from now on in and that way it
kind of exercise it's kind of nice but
you know Mom seeing that moment and
recognizing it and getting emotional hit
me very hard as well where I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's right the secret origin of
all this stuff is that it happened it's
just the names are different you know
Randall says it I think in the trailer
where he's like uh what's the exact line
where he's like I didn't
he's don't look at me
let me [ __ ] hanging uh but yes I know
that's my thoughts I'll turn it over to
the two boys who played various sides me
Brian has played Dante for years and and
that was always kind of my my character
so to speak
Jeff plays Randall of course it was
never me until this version of the movie
when he has my heart attack so what do
you think boys
um the the good thing about Kevin's
scripts are incredibly easy and
relatable to to my upbringing as well he
comes from an Irish Catholic upbringing
as well with a strict mother and a
strict mother but a mother who cares
about their son that they want to keep
you on the straight narrow no you were
right she was strict well
and so uh and a dad who I who I hung out
with a lot as a kid as well so in seeing
that kind of relationship and that's my
upbringing and just saying the words
there was a kind of ease to do in the
dialogue I came from a theater
background so you have to learn an
entire play and perform it in front of a
live audience every night so knowing an
hour and a half of dialogue in your head
at any given time was a benefit because
of the dialogue that Kevin writes the
silver Bose and so for specific that it
was great to do and so doing this all
these years it was it was a lot of me
but definitely his words in my mouth and
uh and that's just the word that sounded
dirty it sounded dirtier than I meant
um it was great it's it's great to have
that kind of dialogue and then to have
such a phenomenal person like Jeff here
who has that that that texture to his
voice and that kind of character that
brings Randall to life and knowing Brian
Johnson in real life and knowing you in
real life and you see you definitely see
the aspects through the the
conversations that subject matter
specifically that Dante and Randall live
uh there and so I'm I'm proud to be
Dante Dante forever I mean I don't want
to step on wakanda's [ __ ] line but
but uh even though I'm not supposed to
be here today uh I I love the the
dialogue of it all and and you know and
that's a testament to Kevin and his
upbringing and just putting down what he
knows he knew what he he liked then you
put it down and I enjoy it I'm glad I'm
doing a third third rendition of this
and I think it's the most powerful
rendition
um I think for me I've never really been
playing Kevin's part it's always Brian
Johnson who Randall is modeled on
um but in this one as soon as I read it
I I realized holy cow I'm actually going
to be doing Kevin's story and uh
there is I I didn't get too heady about
it because I'm not much of an actor so I
don't you know get into that space
um but um there was one thing that I did
put in there uh Kevin has this thing
when he's filming and he gets jazzed he
kind of does this little Snappy thing
yeah and just as a lark I I did that
while Randall was directing that was
that was my little gift to Kevin say I'm
kind of playing you just with my fingers
it was it was awesome and I was watching
the take and at one point generally when
I kind of get like excited they call it
who somebody called it who is it you
call it Josh calls it my impatient dance
live called Josh's wife Liv calls it my
impatient dance it's this
and this is how the magic Works
everybody pretty much you've just seen
behind the scenes and you know I'm
always telling them like that's not me
being impatient like they're like what
is that what do you a lot of people ask
what are you listening to in your head
that you're dancing to and I was like
it's no music that's just the feeling I
get when I'm getting everything that I
want
so at one point during the take like uh
Jeff is playing uh Randall who is
directing a movie
he started doing this and I was behind
the [ __ ] Monitor and I got choked up
where I was like he noticed
okay
we good thank you so much thank you my
friend give it up great question
how are you what's your name hi everyone
my name is Russell Fung
give it up for Russell everybody
what you got Russell what can we do you
for uh I'm really grateful that Brian
and Jeff are here and uh oh my God uh my
questions for Jeff uh I would love to
hear your story and your journey about
what you were going through and what
what got you to change your mind and say
yes to clerks three because we I'm just
very grateful that you get to do this I
get so tired of Kevin sitting around my
house [ __ ] snapping I was like I'll
[ __ ] do it
no
I don't know I I have a sort of a weird
relationship with these movies
um I'm very grateful to do them I have a
great time when I do them but at the
same time it's just not my thing it's uh
it it just I don't know I'm like the
only guy that lives in L.A that doesn't
want to be an actor
and [ __ ] Kevin doesn't understand
that
he moved out of La he moved up into like
the [ __ ] Woods as Jay said he lives
with bears in the [ __ ] woods and
still I'll show up and be like
laughs
that's it all right thank you
um it was thank God uh Jeff said yes man
because that the Randall is the linchpin
to the fair that was the story I
desperately wanted to tell
um a kind of a Randall Ford story it's
not to say that Dante takes a back seat
by any stretch of the imagination but
it's just the journey gets powered by
Randall and of course Dante goes on it
with him and being on that set like you
know we were some it was we shot it last
summer uh we start started on my
birthday August 2nd and uh wrapped like
right before I guess September uh
beginning of September or the first week
of September and there were moments
where you know there were three of us
four of us uh Brian Jeff me and Jason
and then five with uh Marilyn who were
there when we made the first one like
you know when it was not a concept of
like oh I hope people like clerks two or
three this was like I hope people like
this movie that we're making and we all
like rehearsed well into the evenings
and stuff like that so when we were able
to kind of reconvene and here we were
like 28 years later doing almost the
same [ __ ] things in some scenes we're
literally doing the same [ __ ] things
that we did 28 years ago
it was a surreal experience to say the
least but it was also
familial it was like you could only do
this with people who were there with you
from the beginning family
um so I'm so glad we got to do it I'm so
glad you did say yes I'm glad I [ __ ]
pestered you for as long as I did
because your magic him and Trevor are
two people that like like when we
finished clerks three I said to Trevor
like Trevor was in clerks too with us
and then the next thing I think Trevor
did was clerks three I was like don't
[ __ ] wait 16 years to be This
brilliant again and he was like let's
not go nuts
it's so true man and he was just like
well if you do one I'll do one and stuff
and Jeff is kind of like similar but
they're so [ __ ] gifted wait until you
see the two of them have a scene
opposite one another and Randall and
Elias have this relationship we we
established in clerks too but they have
like a [ __ ] drop dead scene in the
third act that's dramatic as [ __ ] that
like Trevor pulls off while wearing an
incredible King Diamond face paint at
the same time spoilers yes so I I'm I'm
glad that you said yes thank you for
that
um okay you my friend what's your name
hello everyone I'm Nico Holt who is it
Nico Holt everyone give it up from Rico
this is my first time in Hall h and I'm
so excited to meet you in person Kevin
Smith welcome I saw you in uh on screen
and uh the LA Comic-Con uh talking about
Stan Stan Lee
um it was incredible experience that I
had and it's an honor to see you thank
you for that the question I have for you
Kevin in the comic book guy on AMC what
was your favorite show on the Comic Book
Guy uh that you have done and who was
your favorite special guest of all the
episodes of comic book man which was my
favorite there was an episode that we'd
we did when I say we as very Loosely I
had the easiest job in the world on that
show the boys would make the show at the
store like you know for weeks they'd
shoot and then I would come in once a
month and shoot the wraparounds like
well what'd you guys do this week and
stuff so so the show was always a
delightful surprise for me as well when
I watched it you know I and I watched it
before it aired I got to watch a cut of
it and stuff I was getting to see stuff
discover stuff for the first time
um in I believe it's the first season if
not maybe the second but there's an
episode where the the boys make a
commercial uh like a cheap knockoff
commercial for Jay and son and Bob's
secret stash and that was Walter
Flanagan's idea and it there was a toy
commercial when we were kids that would
run in our neck of the woods a hobby
store that we went to and bought Comics
called toy Masters and they did a local
commercial that ran on like a local
network and stuff would pop in on cable
and you know it was to say it was stiff
would be an understatement [ __ ] and so
it always captured Walter's imagination
and he didn't want to do Comic Book Men
like I had to Badger him into doing that
and stuff him and Brian Johnson they
were both like no I don't want to be on
TV be so finally when they agreed to do
it like Walter was like look I'll do it
but you can't make me like this
so I was like all right fair enough so
he was doing it and then I got a report
back that like oh we're doing an episode
where we do a fake commercial and my
heart leapt because that was I knew I
knew what that was that was Walter
engaging with the program it was no
longer just happening to him and around
him it was no longer just something that
he was doing because I asked him to do
it captured his imagination and he
realized he could use this to do the
things he always wanted to do and one of
the things he always wanted to do was
make a commercial that made fun of that
commercial that we always watched and
[ __ ] so he built a whole episode
essentially just to do that and when I
saw that I was filled with creative Joy
my friend was one of the Still Remains
one of the funniest people I've ever met
in my life one of the most original and
[ __ ] kind of like absolutely like Jason
Muse but he was not a production guy he
wasn't like me where he gets up on stage
and drives to do things and stuff like
that but he was bit by the bug he was
seized by the moment and suddenly he
kind of took charge and he started
writing more story lines and the best
episodes of Comic Book Men honestly were
the ones that came from Walter because
they were so [ __ ] meaningful and when
he got when he took charge you could see
like how much it meant to him like here
he was going like this could be fun and
[ __ ] so I absolutely loved that episode
where they did the commercial because it
takes me right back to like the first
year of hanging out with Walter in the
like late 80s and being like you're one
of the most original people I've ever
met without Walter I never get to Brody
Bruce Mall Rats never happens and stuff
so he's in the creative DNA of a lot of
what I do and watching him quote unquote
come out of his shell so to speak and
seize his creative power was nothing
short of [ __ ] thrilling even though
it was Comic Book Men man there was this
huge human drama that was going on in
the middle of it where I watched my
friend Ascend creatively it was really
beautiful who was my favorite guest that
we ever had on the show
I mean hands down Stan he was on
multiple episodes there was one episode
where he's sitting on the counter
and the boys are at his feet like just
sitting there listening to him and it's
[ __ ] you know they're all adults on
the ground and [ __ ] like that but it
seemed like the absolute right
relationship and when he was there he
was having a good time like he was
laughing and and and and hooting and
hollering [ __ ] like that like you know
sometimes Stan was over committed and
would do things and you'd get the
impression like this was a favor to
somebody but Stan loved to perform and
stand love to play Stan and we were like
here's a TV show play Stan so he held
court on the show it was absolutely
[ __ ] wonderful and to be able to give
something tiny like that back to a dude
who gave me so much like this was a guy
who fired my imagination as a child and
somebody I'm kind of modeled myself
after as an adult first time I came to
Comic-Con in 1995 Stan was the chairman
emeritus he was the mayor he was he was
Mr Hall h and that didn't even exist at
that point but he was the person I most
just wanted to be at Comic-Con where I
was like that the person who when they
walk into a [ __ ] room everyone's so
happy to see them everyone has a shared
memory of something wonderful that this
[ __ ] did I was like if I could
live my whole life and get to that
[ __ ] place that would be magical and
that's how I feel when I come to
Comic-Con now he ain't here but I feel
him here man
I'm sorry that we keep getting real
emotional on a Saturday night but you
could tell we're all old people and
everything feels
thank you for that question anytime you
get a chance to bring back the dead man
you got to seize it and he was the
finest of us like think about a lot of
us are sitting in this room today
because there is a a track that pop
culture sails Along on consistently the
track was [ __ ] built one of the
Architects was [ __ ] Stan Lee can't
come here without thinking about the guy
and then
you can't come here without thinking
about the guy and who he meant to pop
culture in the world and comics and [ __ ]
and then on a whole different personal
level like I can't come here without
thinking about the guy our friends So
Many Adventures that we had withstand at
Comic-Con Jason talked about the other
night on Jay and Sal and Bob get all the
podcasts that we did at the movies pop
up and stuff how we came to the back
hall h you know they pull you up in a
vehicle and you get out and [ __ ] we got
out as years ago and as we got out of
the vehicle who was getting into the
vehicle but [ __ ] Stanley himself and
Stan Lee for whatever reason loved me
and would always light up when he saw me
be like Kev and he Falcon always
remembered me and even though I stand
next to Jason all the time he never
remembered Jason's name ever
so he would be like hey Kev hey kev's
little buddy and which is weird because
Jason's taller than me whatever but but
he sit there he sat there he chit
chatted with us for a few minutes like
in in the uh you know right in the
parking lot in the area the drop off and
[ __ ] and then his people got him into
his his vehicle he's like all right I'll
see you guys later and he pulled away
and [ __ ] and you know I'd known him at
this point since 95 so it's been years
but Jason had the presence in mind to be
like could you imagine going back in
your in your life go back to being a kid
and tell tell yourself that one day when
you come to Comic-Con the first [ __ ]
first person that's gonna greet you is
Stan Lee and he's happy to [ __ ] see
you
beautiful [ __ ] observation that I
never would have thought of I was on my
way to a panel so Stan was something I
was like hey man how are you and I had
the exchange and off he went thankfully
Jason stopped the world just to be like
Jesus Christ look how far we've come
from Jersey to Stanley's [ __ ] friends
man like really really powerful [ __ ]
and there was one time my [ __ ] we
were doing a signing on the floor it was
an end cap stage they built up it's only
like three three stairs high and we were
doing a signing at this table and Stan
rolled by to say hello and [ __ ] this is
a few years after Mallrats you got to
remember like [ __ ] when we met him he
was already an old man like when he came
to us on Mallrats he was already
great-haired he was 76 when we shot
Mallrats and I remember uh Jim Jacks the
producer was like be careful with him he
could die at any minute and [ __ ] he
lived 20 more years he outlived Jim
Jacks it was crazy and [ __ ]
so you know he Stan came up to say hi to
us and [ __ ] and we were like Stan and we
were chit chatting and meanwhile people
were there to get signatures were just
staring in awe there were no cell phones
this was before the cell phone camera so
it wasn't a sea of phones in our faces
it was just people experiencing the
moment going oh my god look they know
each other and [ __ ] like that so we
chit-chatted for a second he's like all
right I'm off to my thing because Stan
was always [ __ ] busy and stuff so
he's heading off the stage remember it's
only three steps up from the ground and
[ __ ] and he's like bye spider friends
and turns and goes face first off the
[ __ ] stage man bam onto the [ __ ]
ground all those people who were there
didn't save them
and he instantly bounced the [ __ ] back
up like a super pick he was like bye
kids and kept [ __ ] going man
absolute [ __ ] magic thank you for
bringing him back for a few minutes man
that felt good how are you I'm good
what's your name uh Carlos Carlos
everyone give it up for Carlos man
Carlos gonna be the one of the last ones
oh [ __ ] all right
um the pressure's on now right a little
bit yeah uh well I guess now uh thank
you Kevin for inspiring me to become a
filmmaker when I was a teenager because
I was like if this counts the movie I
can do this right absolutely man that's
the key to this [ __ ] is you look at it
and I remember slacker was the movie
that did it for me Richard link later
slacker and I've I've spoken many times
about how I viewed the movie with a
mixture of awe and arrogance all because
I was like I've never seen anything like
this this is [ __ ] incredible you can
do this this counts as a movie and she
had holy [ __ ] and then arrogance because
I was like I think I could [ __ ] do
this if this counts as a movie [ __ ] I
might be able to pull this off and so
years later I made you know [ __ ]
clerks and other people saw it and
that's the compliment they give me the
most which is like your movie looks so
[ __ ] bad that I figured I should give
it a shot you know so thank you that
means the [ __ ] world in a weird
backhanded compliment kind of way
my mom is a good my mom's good at that
so fast and right up anyway uh with the
precipice of Clerks three being released
um instant streaming is a whole new
thing too
possible clerks animated series Revival
I'm hoping for it oh I would love we
talk about this all the time because it
was the easiest job any of us ever had
man you could show up in your pajamas
and record voices [ __ ] I played Silent
Bob so I got paid for no voice
whatsoever
um the version that we did that
particular iteration with Leonardo
Leonardo Mr plug all that stuff if we
were to do that the only way we could do
it It's oddly enough it's owned by
Disney
but Disney would never [ __ ] put it
anywhere near Disney plus
um it was made while we were it was made
for ABC and ABC Disney owns ABC so they
technically own it that leaves one place
to potentially do it and that is Hulu so
the moment that solar opposites hit when
Justin show hit man I called my agent I
was like can you [ __ ] call up Hulu
and tell them like we got a cartoon man
that could go right next to solar
opposites and [ __ ] and it's got all the
designs are done and like we got scripts
like ready to go we've been waiting and
[ __ ] like that and the word came back
from uh Hulu that like uh we're good
and I was like what is that so are we
going to pitch so like they don't even
want to hear the pitch so
we can make that show is through a very
thin [ __ ] tightrope at Hulu now we
could make a clerks cartoon it just
wouldn't be that Clerk's cartoon I have
the rights to go make a clerks cartoon
anywhere I want but that particular
iteration I couldn't do so we figure if
there's enough of a good response
positive response to clerks three then
it's going to be a lot easier to walk
into a streamer and be like how would
you like to do a clerks cartoon so that
depends on y'all man if you get your
tickets at clerks3.movie
perhaps it paves the way for us to get
back to the cartoon or an even better
cartoon man
or hashtag Hulu bring back clerks to
cartoon yes yeah
that's true that could work
thank you for that listen and it had the
butthole cut of cats for [ __ ] sake
trending at one time true good point uh
go ahead we'll take you absolutely
what's your name Captain
uh thank you Kevin my name is Aaron
Aaron everyone give it up for Aaron man
just wanted to say lots of us were
waiting in line for you and not Marvel
so happy to be here thank you man thank
you you all missed out because Marvel
rocked you're rocking pretty good too so
just just want to say you're about as
polar opposite for me as a person that
like you you and I are totally different
people but every time I come to hear you
speak at Hall h
uh I am supercharged like a Green
Lantern sticking his hand in the battery
for my writing and I just can't say how
much I appreciate that so number one
[ __ ] that is an eloquent compliment
my writer friend instantly evocative I
saw myself sticking my hand into the
[ __ ] Lantern well done uh number two
I love any creative man if you're a
writer if you're somebody out there
that's just like oh I got an idea pursue
it do it write it you don't know if it's
going to go anywhere but it'll never go
anywhere if it [ __ ] lives here take
it from here to one other step and see
what happens stranger things not that
[ __ ] show but stranger things have
happened then it could become your
career you're looking at a bunch of
people up here who like made a movie
just to see if we could and it literally
became our careers uh for a lot of us it
should so be Creative Kids it's nice to
listen to creative people and [ __ ] but
it should fire you up like he like he's
talking about make you want to go out
there and do [ __ ] on your own make your
own [ __ ] [ __ ] man
okay
what's your name
hi my name is Camille Camille everyone
give it up for Camille
floor is yours Camille well first of all
I was here when you talked about your
heart attack too and I wanted to say I
just think that took incredible balls to
stay in front of so many people and I
know a lot of people that aren't fans
that I've played that for that were just
amazed and then went on to look at a lot
of your work and enjoy it so [ __ ] hey
man thank you see that heart attack was
very valuable for me it made people
reconsider me in many different ways
do you think if we had another one we
could do the cartoon yeah oh okay hold
on I feel it coming on Elizabeth
Jacob for the team kid
someone Paul Hulu
so to me like I I think your work's
funny it's honest it's clearly a labor
of love but lots of things are but when
I think the real magic has been is the
relationships you have all cultivated
with each other that have allowed you to
keep doing all of this and I think that
says something really exceptional about
all of you yeah
that's good and the bad and all of that
I think that's pretty amazing and it's
clear that you all show each other a lot
of respect and affection I think that's
really awesome
so my question is I wanted to know I
actually wanted to know from all of you
either what question you wish people
would ask you or what you still really
hope to do in your career right now that
is an excellent [ __ ] question give it
up for that [ __ ]
and what a great way to wrap this all up
it shall be man we'll start right here a
two-parter and what are the two parts
again I'm a stoner so I already forgot I
actually had asked you at the last one
what work you still wanted to do and you
actually mentioned this though but so
what I wanted to know was either what
question you guys wish people would ask
you but they never have or what you're
really hoping to still do with your
career like what your dream is to do
that you have enough love it starting
with you Austin uh for the I'm gonna
answer the second uh part of that
question first
um and like a lot of the people asking
uh questions here I want to uh make
movies myself one day
um because I've been doing acting for a
while and uh yeah I wanna
dabble in that area
um and
a question that
I wish people would ask me would be
Austin's dating my daughter be very
careful
I know I'm trying to think
um
do you know that taco cat spelled
backwards is taco cat and I would say
yes it is
thank you
that's so stupid I'll come up with a
better one
you have my permission to marry my
daughter
wait for real
over to you Marilyn
um I I don't even know
how to answer that first part I I just I
just don't but as far as like the second
question
um
I mean I can only hope that this will be
in
a definite
you know breaking point for me to
continue to do this to make me get more
auditions that
actually have more substance to them
uh I'm not talking about this
substance yeah the movie's not out yet
you can still be caught Marilyn
I'll be honest with you Maryland Marilyn
I'm talking about the auditions that I
do get true yeah let me I will pay you a
compliment to pull you out of this hole
you're digging for yourself
uh Marilyn uh came and she uh did a
scene when I wrote the scenes uh for
Veronica in clerks three they were very
cuttable they don't push the narrative
forward
um they're essentially let's stop the
movie to enjoy somebody coming back but
in a world of editing it's one thing I'm
a hell of a nice writer and I'm really
wonderful director but when it comes to
being an editor I will serve the story
so you may get [ __ ] cut so that role
was always in my head like you know we
could always cut the Veronica scene it
doesn't really Propel the story forward
and then Maryland showed up and dropped
a [ __ ] performance Clinic she took a
scene that like I said was [ __ ]
cuttable and that's the writer director
and editor saying that and she made it
absolutely dazzlingly uncuttable we all
stopped just to [ __ ] watch her act
man it was pretty damn impressive
thank you
um
thank you
um no it's thank you for the scene to
begin with you made it better kid I'm
sorry I elevated it I literally
went in there to prove something more to
myself to really
make that scene my own and show the
world what I've been able to accomplish
since the first one
you do
you do absolutely do that in the movie
so thank you um
however give it up for a man
but um
thank you um however as your director
I'm going to point out there's a very
easy to defer answer to the first
question if somebody's like uh what's
the thing you've never been asked you've
always wanted to be asked you just say
would you like a million dollars that
would be nice yes
um but I've I've already directed my
first little short film that I entered
into your Film Festival did you I always
should man so that's you know just
dabbling here and there and just kind of
trying to learn as much of everything
else as possible so and hopefully bigger
and better things to come I had a girl
thank you
captain
question I wish if someone would ask me
that no one's ever asked me is Trevor
how did you become the most handsome man
in the world and also the world's
greatest ninja
as for what I'd like to do with my
career I'd really like to do the clerks
cartoon so could you eat a cheeseburger
or something
I hope I do drop dead you'll feel so bad
for the next
month I don't I don't find any of this
[ __ ] funny though yeah this guy's
like don't [ __ ] make jokes about my
meal ticket [ __ ]
no I don't know you know for years
people have been like oh Kevin's your
meal ticket it's vice versa ladies and
gentlemen the character of Jay is not a
creation of my imagination the character
Jay is based on Jay himself and who he
was when he was 16 years old so the
character is eternally 16 and you know I
watched the open in a few minutes of the
movie with everybody and it was
wonderful to hear everybody Welcome
[ __ ] Brian welcome Jeff but like when
Jay and Silent Bob came out man it was
like [ __ ] magic the roof blew off and
that's everything to do with Jason Muse
the he the character exists because of
him Silent Bob only exists so that Jay
has somebody to talk at
give it up for Jason Muse man oh stop it
I I didn't want anything bad to happen
to my best friend but thanks bro
[Laughter]
um is it my turn yeah it is I wish
someone would ask me if I bleach my
[ __ ]
I'll do it right now we don't ask
[Laughter]
me uh and the answer is yes what and
what do I want to do was that what the
thing was what was the second part what
you'd really like to do in your career
if you were given the opportunity to do
yeah
you'd be in a [ __ ] Marvel I want to
be you know what in my career I guess
this would be career thing I really want
to be I want to add to the handprints I
want to hit the trifecta and get the
star on the Walk of Fame and I want to
become a wax figure
that would be cool at the Wax Museum you
know it's such a it's such an a quaint
oddly old Hollywood notion where you're
like three levels of success are getting
your feet in the in the cement of the
grow men's Chinese Theater I can get
that that's the rare air that we're
breathing getting your [ __ ] star on a
Hollywood Walk of Fame like I get that
there's not a lot of people in the world
can do that
but who told you that wax figures was
like the Pinnacle of success like if you
got a wax figure you [ __ ] made it son
you know why because I [ __ ] I went to
when they uh unveiled Danny Trejo's and
right next to it was [ __ ] Obama and
[ __ ]
and when part of the Golden Girls
[ __ ]
so [ __ ] weird
you're right I'm thinking about this all
wrong
[ __ ] Obama be Arthur and you
[Laughter]
oh God I'm gonna die Danny
Ariana Grande Danny Trejo The Golden
Girls and Obama [ __ ]
[Laughter]
if that's not a Marvel movie in phase
six I don't know what is
you know I didn't have an answer for
that first part but I just came up with
it I'm dying for somebody to ask me if I
want to be a wax figure
and do I want to be right next to Jay's
bleached [ __ ] hell yeah
uh the second part of it I don't really
have career aspirations but I will say I
I told Trevor this and I think it's the
only person uh I've told this
um a while back I wrote a movie called
now you know wrote and directed a movie
called now you know and that's where we
found Trevor since I've been doing the
cons and getting out and people have
said such nice things about my movie
I've actually started writing a new
script oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] rocks
so we'll see
attaboy and you thought wakanda forever
was a cool reveal
[Laughter]
oh my God you salty [ __ ]
I have a seat Marvel Studios
well he was like do you realize that all
these other Studios were the hour
warm-up Act and where the headliner
tonight
[Applause]
I don't know man I saw that Guardians
trailer yeah it's pretty amazing so uh a
question I would uh love to be asked
would be um would you want to join us as
part of this cast of this new Star Wars
movie
[Laughter]
it is only maybe five people in the
planet that could actually ask that
question with legit follow-up
um and uh secondly I guess is kind of
connected
um I would love somehow because I
badgered my really poor working class
Irish family to spend stupid amounts of
money they really didn't have for tons
of Star Wars toys back in the 70s when
that movie came out because it changed
my life like it changed Kevin's life I
remember we lived in the Bronx in New
York City we drove out to this 70
millimeter theater out in Paramus New
Jersey to go see a 70 millimeter print
of the film now remember my two older
brothers one is 10 years older one is
nine years older than me or six years
old let me excuse me and uh coming back
out of that movie and I'm like yeah that
was so great I'm like oh I can't wait
till I get my own land speeder when I
can drive
it's uh quite a bit of time since 77 and
I still don't have my goddamn land
speeder
I can pretend to drive one in a Star
Wars movie so if I could get somehow
involved in a Star Wars franchise I
think uh I'm very jealous of Rosario to
be honest with you I know right I would
love to be a part of that I know you
voiced a a stormtrooper uh in the Star
Wars movie so um that would be my I'm
not it's not quite wax figure level of
uh yes aim higher man yeah James or
Madame Tussauds yes Jeff is your
screenplay a Star Wars movie
say what is Jeff's I was asking this
joke's not going anywhere pale
did you hit the second question oh the
Star Wars one yeah
join us give it up for Brian that's just
me pandering for that no that's smart
you don't get unless you ask
um what question would I like somebody
to ask me that they haven't asked me
um it'd be nice if somebody was like can
I make moose Jaws that'd be great
maybe one day someone will ask that
um I'm gonna go a little poignant
because it's late and I'm a middle-aged
Stoner but question I would love to be
asked is do you want to go to the movies
and I would just love to be asked that
by my father one last [ __ ] time man
I'd say [ __ ] yes we're going to see that
guardian's picture old man
and he'd been dead for a while so I'd
have to explain the franchise to him and
[ __ ] but but after that we'd have a damn
good time
um what do I want for the future or what
do I hope to do with yet to accomplish
that I haven't accomplished yet I'll be
honest with you uh life's and this
business has been very good to me either
that or I have very low aspirations
because I've been able to accomplish
most of the things that I've ever wanted
to accomplish like a good 95 percent of
them and [ __ ] and the ones that I
haven't been able to do aren't like
breaking my heart to not do and I also
figure well life is long and I got
something to look forward to maybe I'll
get there and stuff but I do have one
ambition that I would love to share with
you all for the future and that's that I
want to come back and do this all again
next year ladies and gentlemen
you have made me and my friends feel so
[ __ ] welcome thank you so much all H
give it up for Austin thank you
Trevor Jay Jeff and Brian ladies and
gentlemen have a great Comic-Con good
night
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this has been the
Hall age panel
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old I'm Kevin
Smith
thank you